[Music]
foreign
I've been living with this character for
eight years
we laughed cheered cried together
the core pillar of this franchise is
figuring out who you really are and
what's worth fighting for
Creed 3 I wanted to know what a
dinosaur's limits were so to be able to
finally step behind the camera
continue to elevate and evolve this
story it's something I'm externally
grateful for
[Music]
Storyteller you really put a piece of
yourself into your films from personal
desires and goals to shortcomings
failures mistakes here's what happens
he was like brothers
I was the best though but I never got a
chance to prove that
Creed 3 is not just your typical boxing
movie we really want to take advantage
of the emotional journey of the
characters and put that into the ring
and have it pay off in a physical way
something is going on with you Damien
was like family
oh we passed talking then maybe you just
have to find him do what I gotta do some
of my methods you might disagree with me
this is the first sports film to be shot
on IMAX cameras with the IMAX experience
you can take in the environment in a way
that you normally wouldn't
be able to see every beat of sweat every
impact the ripples in the skin the
sounds of the footsteps the punches the
music the lack of sound and really
immerse yourself into the entire world
I'm coming for everything you
threatening me everybody has a past
everybody has things that they wish they
could have done differently
so to be able to see a character like a
dinosaur go through some of those things
I hope audiences walk away feeling
inspired and I have the courage to do
something that you normally wouldn't do
[Music]
let go of whatever was and walk into
what is I want people to walk away from
this movie feeling better than they did
when they walked in I think that's
something that's powerful about Cinema
[Applause]
foreign
living out my wildest dreams
Bianca Rocky
my dad
was built on their shoulders
hey mama can I help you let me get
autograph no I ain't sounding an
autographs but you get off my car y'all
remember me huh
foreign
[Music]
how long were you locked up 18 Years bro
she's got out last week
I know I've been away a long time but I
got myself in shape I still got gas in
the tank come by the gym
thank you
[Music]
curious what happened with you too oh
you can tell you he was like brothers
I was the best though man I never got a
chance to prove that that's cute
you don't always do nothing
Damien's fighting the world he's trying
to hurt people I bounce for you you
think you mad trying to spending half
your life in a cell
why does somebody else live your life
I'm coming for everything you
threatening me
something is going on with you
Batman was like family
[Music]
now we passed talking then maybe you
just have to find out
I recognize mine I know that they needed
me yet
I need you to call your fear
they're called a guilt
that God whatever was and walk into what
is I feel those chains are breaking yeah
[Music]
[Music]
thank you